I want to make a quick correction to the
last video doesn't really a fleck affect
the learning of the last video but I
just want to make sure that we that you
understand that I got the math a little
bit wrong in the last video I I said
that you know you had to state three
hundred thousand years so we talked
about the Big Bang happening 13.7
billion 13.7 billion years ago and then
I talked about this state of affairs the
state of affairs where maybe we're maybe
thirty million light years away from the
edge of the observable universe the
current observable universe and I said
that this was about 300,000 300,000
years after after the Big Bang that's
what I talked about in the last video
that was our starting point when the
photon started leaving that point and
obviously the universe kept expanding
the photon kind of had it kind of
traversed more and more but still had
more and more to travel as the universe
expanded is all of space expanded but
this is 300,000 years after the Big Bang
now my brain because I was kind of not
thinking hard enough about it I said hey
this was thirteen point four billion
years ago that's what I incorrectly said
in the last video I said that this is
thirteen point four billion years ago
years ago that's what I said in the last
video and that is wrong because if this
was thirteen point four billion years
ago this would have been 300 million
years after the Big Bang we were talking
about only 300,000 years after the Big
Bang so it wouldn't have taken that many
decimal places off of something in the
billions it was still the correct
answers this would have been this would
have been only a little less than 13.7
billion years it would actually wouldn't
have even made the significant digit so
this is still approximately 13.7 billion
13.7 billion years ago so I wanted to
just make that correction it was a
slight error I shouldn't have you this
as 0.3 billion years this is only 0.3
million years it doesn't even it doesn't
even basically change the precision on
this number right over here so I just
wanted to clear that up and but
hopefully it doesn't effect
our understanding too much